advertising in of itself is the process
of making known if no one knows about
your stuff no one can buy it what
happens is most people have an offer and
no one knows about it and so you have to
make it known you have to advertise it I
talk about the advertising cycle so the
first four is a core four it's the only
four ways any person can let other
people know about their stuff it's just
a four box there's oneone and one to
many and you've got people who know you
people who don't so if you're letting
people who know you oneon-one you doing
warm Outreach you reach out to your
friends and say hey come to my book
event if you're letting people know
oneon-one who don't know you that's cold
Outreach that's out to strangers if
you're letting people know one to many
two people who know you that's posting
content and if you're letting people one
to many know who don't know you that's
running ads so these the only four
things that you can do to let other
people know about your stuff